hospitalizations are also down in
america part of a weeks-long
trajectory but the good news is not
evenly distributed when it comes to
vaccinations of americans
who receive their first dose through
january 14th
60 percent have been white compared with
much smaller numbers for other groups
according to the cdc
our lead national correspondent david
begno is in south los angeles david good
morning
good morning anthony this is an ongoing
success story
kedran psychiatric hospital was erected
in the 1960s during the watts riots
and since then they have served some of
the most underserved communities black
and brown populations living in here in
south central l.a let me tell you
something they have tackled vaccine
administration and they are getting it
done
effectively word has gotten out that
what's happening here is working
fifteen thousand doses have already been
administered on site
and there were some folks who started
lining up at three a.m this morning
waiting for the gates to open
here's the doctor leading it all
seniors essential health care workers
appointments dr
jerry abraham is a man on a mission
registration team how's everybody
he's got a crowd of eager angelenos
wrapped around the block
almost all of them are from some of los
angeles most
underserved communities we are literally
every morning till every night doing
everything we can to help get this whole
county vaccinated
what drives you you sound quite
passionate i mean
people are dying my patients are dying
sylvia victor lives close by
she lined up at 3 a.m she's a caregiver
for her 17 year old son jesus
who has cerebral palsy and she's
eligible for the vaccine
how long have you tried to get a vaccine
well to make an appointment more than
one week
and it is not working the website so
it's very tough to get that appointment
and dr abraham knows that that's why
kedran
registers people right here on site they
don't understand that grandma and
grandpa don't even have an email address
much less a phone
so what are you talking about just keep
checking the website what internet do
they have
those are just some of the barriers here
in what he calls
a medical desert dr abraham's team
is relentless in finding and
administering vaccines
they give about 2 000 a day locals 65
and older get to go first
then it's health care workers and if
there are doses left at the end of every
day
they are made available to anyone
waiting outside
we refuse to let any drop go to waste
here at kedron
i think now that ward has gotten out
that we prioritize people over data
entry
people have now found their way as
you've seen behind me
to kedran including susan she's a lawyer
who lives in an upscale neighborhood
about 30 minutes away
there are people who say folks like you
right wealthy
live in ritzy areas come to south l.a
impoverished area
to sort of cut in line what would you
what would you say well i don't think
i'm
cutting in line i mean i would let
somebody in front of me who was older
that's what they do here at the end of
the day
look dr abraham says if there is an
available dose it'll go to susan
and anyone like her but we are going to
help our neighbors that is part of our
mandate our ethical
commitment our moral compass we're used
to getting
forgotten about or left behind and i
think that's why we're so good at coming
together
and now i want this success this south
la success
this historically black institution's
success to be the success of the county
of los
angeles and south l.a
about that dr abraham listen he and his
team are constantly working the phones
calling nursing homes and hospitals in
the area saying hey do you have leftover
doses because if you do and they're
going bad today
bring them here and we will get them
into somebody's arm before the sun sets
tony one more thing i noticed yesterday
in being here
that there are so many people who are
responsible for making things run
effectively and helping dr abraham and a
lot of those people are community
organizers
who showed up at the gate knocked on it
and said i want to help
yeah it takes a village and our thanks
to all of them but we share
your words how about that dr abraham
david thank you very much